let's talk to women and girls in
afghanistan about what life is like
under the taliban
[Applause]
because some of the biggest changes in
the last year target this half of the
population
[Music]
every afghan woman and every afghan girl
has her own take on what's going on
and we've come to afghanistan to hear
from at least a few of them
[Music]
first though let's get a sense of what
some of the new rules are under this
taliban government many of which came
from this place the ministry of vice and
virtue which replaced the old ministry
for women's affairs it's rules like
women aren't allowed to travel long
distances without a close male relative
and in may the taliban said women had to
cover their faces in full while in
public in fact you'll see posters just
like this one across the country there
have been other big changes too
thousands of women have been stopped
from going back to their government jobs
they're essentially being paid to sit at
home and then there's the issue of girls
education girls can go to primary school
and university but not secondary school
now these rules are not totally black
and white and there's definitely some
inconsistency with how the taliban are
applying and enforcing them
they also say the restrictions on school
and work are only temporary
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so then why are there all these
restrictions well the taliban have given
different reasons like there are
problems with girls school uniforms and
they're working out how to separate men
and women in government offices isn't it
as simple as putting women in one room
and men in another
idea is
la mega
tafsir has taken on the taliban directly
on afghan tv
are you afraid at all though about
speaking out no
i'm not afraid why we should afraid
we're talking about something right
what you have to remember is that when
the taliban were in power in the 1990s
there were strict rules for men and
women and violent punishment for those
who broke them
girls over eight weren't allowed any
kind of education and women had to cover
up completely
after the u.s invasion in 2001 the
taliban were kicked out and a new
constitution helped protect the rights
of women
over the last 20 years access to
education work and health care improved
especially for more well-off women
living in the cities but the taliban see
it as a time when afghanistan was losing
its core islamic values
and now that they're back in charge they
say they're restoring islamic order and
governing in accordance with islamic law
at least their interpretation of it
afghanistan
is
and that position does have support
including from women
[Music]
but that idea that under the old
government women were somehow not acting
in accordance with islam well a lot of
afghans reject that especially when it
comes to what women wear have you
changed the way you dress
no before i was like because i am
afghan woman i am muslim woman wife i
should change before i am like this
now i am also like this i like my
husband i like my afghan culture
we've been speaking to a lot of afghan
women and men who say we don't need the
taliban to tell us
how to dress how to behave how to be
muslim and how to be afghan
if they were here right now how would
you respond to that
s
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's get into that issue of girls
and school
in almost all provinces schools are shut
for girls from grade 7 to 12.
around 850 000 teenage girls have missed
out on formal education since the
taliban took over they took our chance
for
improving and also for
educating for following our lessons
[Music]
we have no opportunity right now i left
my goals i cannot achieve that goal so
i'm
out of motivation right now
i feel i miss something something very
important
especially the books which are my best
friends remember
my
these girls are still managing to study
a little in this private institute their
tuition is paid for by a charity they're
learning web design and coding for 4
hours a week it's no substitute for high
school but it's something
that
[Music]
[Music]
she's 21 and is applying to universities
abroad
she spends her days drawing
all her friends left last year and she
wants to go too
to escape what she sees as the sudden
lack of freedom and opportunity in her
own country i was used to go out of my
friends alone without no guy no one my
brother or my father but now i can't
it's a big change for me so my dream my
idea was to be someone to work and to
show that no african girls are capable
of doing a lot of things
they can they can take risks they can do
a lot of challenging things like other
girls around the world like they have
talents they have great abilities they
can help people they can be independent
and i still have hope that maybe one day
i will be able to do it
[Music]
it's impossible to generalize how all
afghan women feel right now and we've
heard a real mix
from fear and disillusion to hope and
defiance in the end it's a personal
thing so we ask the women and girls we
spoke to what they want the world to
know
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
watch our other episode out of
afghanistan all about why the economy is
in such a bad shape and how that's
affecting people we've linked it here
you